Hello everybody welcome to today's webinar
on PubMed Tools and ORCID Identifiers for
Authors. My name is Peter Cooper and I will
be monitoring the questions pod. Marie Collins
is going to be presenting.
During the webinar if you have a question
please put it into the questions pod, I will
try to address simple questions while Marie
is talking. If there are more complicated
ones, or the ones that everybody needs to
hear answers to I will read them to Maria
at the end. If there are any we don't get
to or to which we don't know the answer, I
will make available a questions and answers
document that will be available linked to
our webinar courses page. There is a directory
that has the slides on the ftp site, there
is a go.usa.gov/xRHaV URL at the bottom of
the slide, I will send that out to everybody.
With that I will turn this over to Marie Collins,
who is part of the PubMed team here at NCBI.
Hi welcome to today's NCBI minute. I will
be talking about author disambiguation and
the strategies and tools in PubMed that will
help you create a comprehensive and precise
list of publications for an author, whether
the author is you or someone else.
Let me get to the agenda slide, we will talk
about the advantage of registering for an
ORCID ID, which is a unique author identifier
you can submit with your publications to PubMed
or include in your bibliography or CV. Beyond
that we will talk about tools that will help
you manage your own bibliography. This gives
you the control to tweak and customize your
citation list, then decide if you want to
share it or assign a delegate to assist with
managing it.
When I talk about ambiguation or disambiguation
in PubMed, there are two flavors of ambiguous
author names. There is the case, and we see
this a lot in PubMed, where there is a single
author published under many names, if they
had changed their surname for any reason,
got married, this adds a layer of complexity.
Always search with the last name and initials.
The three names you see here. Smith, Smith
Jones, and Jones are three unique last names
in PubMed. For complete retrieval for this
author's citations you should use the OR to
combine the various names that the author
has published with. The second flavor of ambiguity
comes from a single name that could belong
to many different authors in PubMed. The best
way to search is for last name and initials.
In this case I am searching for young m, I'm
getting more than 4000 results. The fastest
way to narrow this down is to add a middle
initial if I know it. Another way is to add
topics. Since I am looking for the Nobel Prize
winning scientist who studied circadian clocks,
I could add that term here.
But since I know the middle name, I will add
a w, this will target my search.
Another way to confirm this is the author
you are looking for, beyond the middle initial
or narrowing your subject terms, is looking
at the affiliation data. I have additional
evidence that this is that M, W, young I am
looking for. He's affiliated with the lab
at the Rockefeller Univerisity. We have included
the affiliation data for all authors since
October 2013. In December 2014 we have accepted
multiple affiliations for authors. These data
really helps us identify whether or not we
found the author that we are actually looking
for.
If I click on the author name from the abstract
view, the 138 citations in my result list
will be sorted by computed author, which weighs
important citation information like subject
terms, co-authors and affiliations, and clusters
them in order that they are most likely from
the same person. We think this algorithm is
very successful since we see users find what
they are looking for on the first page or
two of the results when they sort this way.
I am not published in PubMed, so I cannot
use my own name, but if you are an author,
searching for your own citations in PubMed
it would be very easy to choose a starting
point, view the citation in abstract view,
and to click on your name.
You will see this sort by author label above
your results. Of course we know some of these
retrieval methods may include some that are
not yours or leave out some that are especially
if you changed your name. We accept unique
identifiers. The publisher can submit this
number with the citation data. Publishers
can update existing records and add identifiers
retrospectively. This unique author identifier
is part of that Sort by author algorithm we
just saw. In addition to co-authors, affiliation
data, subject terms, and your name, we are
also adding in the ORCID ID, which helps with
sort by author.
ORCID , if you are not familiar stands for
Open Researcher and Contributor Identification.
It is a persistent identifier and an industry
standard that can be applied not just to scholarly
publishing but other areas of research and
sharing, such as data, blogs, software codes,
and much more. It has become a broadly accepted
mechanism for identifying ownership of research.
It's continued success depends on the collaboration
between researchers, publishers, universities,
granting agencies and other stakeholders in
scholarly communications. I think that NLM
falls solidly in the last category as a stakeholder.
We are encouraging all researchers to register
for ORCID ID that they submit with there publications
and other output.
We've integrated ORCID with our SciENcv platform
which aids in the creation of the NIH Biosketch
used in the grant management process. The
advantage of ORCID ID, is that it is a persistent
identifier unlike a name that could change
over time. You can search in PubMed just by
entering the ORCID ID, you do not need to
add a field tag to it, PubMed is really good
sensing that you are searching for the ORCID
ID based on the pattern of that number.
In addition to the author sort, additional
affiliation information and the inclusion
of ORCID ID, my Bib, My Bibliography is a
powerful tool that lets you save and share
your citations. You can sign in to My NCBI
with your existing Google, NIH or ERA Commons
account. If you click on the link there, See
more third-party sign in options, this will
include many universities and you can use
your existing credentials to register for
My NCBI as well. Or create an independent
account just for NCBI. The process is intuitive,
but you can always contact the support center
if you run into trouble.
This is the My NCBI homepage just to set some
context if you have never looked at this before.
You can customize this page, reorganize these
portals on the page, think of these as Windows
into an existing NCBI resource.
You can create and share your bibliography,
even if you are not applying for grants or
managing grant reporting, however much of
the features and design of My Bib came in
parallel with the NIH Public Access compliance
needs. It helps with reporting the progress
of the scientific research. There are four
ways to build your bibliography, I will go
over them now.
From within PubMed the process is simple,
you execute an author search, select some
citations, and then use the send to menu to
send citations to your bibliography.
Click on save. You will get an explicit confirmation
and you will be returned to PubMed, because
that is where you started, but there is a
link at the top and the bottom that says Edit
your bibliography, this will take you back
to your My Bib page to edit your bibliography.
If you want to add citations while you are
in your My NCBI account, click on My NCBI
to get started. This link appears at the top
of all PubMed pages. Then click on Manage
my bibliography there in the My Bib portal.
You will see the three options next to your
bibliography. If you do not have any journal
articles they will not appear, I have been
adding citations that are not my own to my
bibliography, you can see this is populated
and then I have the three options for adding
citations. If you click on Add from PubMed,
you will see a search box, you can execute
your search from within My Bib.
On this screen you can select citations to
add and it shows citations that are already
part of your bibliographies. If you see anything
with a greyed out checkmark and grey text,
you can tell that those are already in your
bibliography and not an option for adding.
To get to this screen, again, we're starting
by clicking My NCBI, manage my bibliography,
then from the menu you saw before, select,
Add manually, to get this form you can fill
in. There's a picklist at the top, we have
selected Books and chapters, which is not
something that traditionally appears, so you
would not necessarily have a citation to import.
The other options on the list include Journal
articles that do not appear in PubMed, meeting
abstracts, presentations, patents, data sets
or database, software and I think a couple
others. If you select upload a file. You will
use your browser's file management system
to upload any Medline or bibliography citation
files.
You can see the two options available. A medline
file. Then an mbib, a bibliography citation
format.
Now you have a bibliography and you can change
the settings, make Public or Private, you
can share the URL if the collection is public,
you can edit settings, look at letter B, I
will go into that part in more detail.
Where you see the letter C, you can modify
your display settings. You can see right now
it says List view, sort by date, group by
citation type. There are other options you
can explore there.
You can look at these actions that are available,
they are all very intuitive. You can move
citations from your bibliography to another
collection. A bibliography is just a special
collection within My NCBI named for you, it
behaves like any other collection you have
created. You can move citations, delete citations,
copy them, and view. You can also suggest.
This is the one feature that you may not have
anticipated or are familiar with. You can
actually check next to a citation, you can
suggest for example to a co-author that they
add it to their bibliography as well. When
you send that suggestion through email they
have a chance to review it and either accept
or refuse that suggestion.
I put this letter E here so that you can see
how many links are available there. This is
a bibliography but there are a lot of links
in the results in PubMed, you can link to
the PubMed citation if you click on the title,
or if the fulltext is available it will tell
you. You can link out to the free full text.
You can also find Related citations. I encourage
you to explore this page. It's very intuitive
but there is extensive online help for my
bibliography.
I will go ahead and look at what we see if
we click on Edit settings. Because my bibliography
is public, I will see a direct URL and the
HTML that I can add to webpages and blogs.
If my bibliography was set to private, those
options would not be available for sharing,
but that is how you share your bibliography,
either email your URL to people or they have
the HTML to embed in a webpage or blog.
You can assign delegates as well. You do this
through the Account Settings page. You can
see that you can link at the bottom of your
My Bibliography settings, but this is the
same if I clicked on my username at the top
of the page, that will take me to my settings
and I can assign a delegate.
Now if I go to My NCBI settings, you can see
delegates option. I can Add a delegate. It
just is a matter of adding the person's email
and then selecting the service I want them
to be a delegate for, whether just My Bibliography,
or My bib and SciENcv, which is a tool we
use to take all of this bibliography information,
helping in the processing and exporting of
that data into an NIH Biosketch or other types
of Biosketches, format, that are available.
Today I talked about ORCID IDs and My bibliographt
in the context of author disambiguation, and
tools for identifying, collecting and sharing
your citations.
These tools are also a very powerful part
of the grant application and compliance process.
Very quickly I want to show that My Bib has
even more features if you have logged in with
your ERA Commons account or have linked the
two accounts.
This helps track citations and manage the
compliance progress. If you are not familiar
ERA Commons, it is an online interface where
grant applicants, grantees and federal staff
at NIH and granting agencies can access and
share information related to research grants.
If you look at this page you can see there
are actually different symbols whether exclamtion
points or yellow that will tell you the status
of these citations in terms of the funding
process.
So today in this NCBI Minute I mentioned a
lot of tools and processes, but didn't cover
them in depth. Here are some links to additional
short webinars you can watch. I listed in
order of relevance to today's presentation.
If you do nothing else and you are involved
in the grant management process, it would
be very helpful spending the 17 minutes watching
the first two videos, and if you want to discover
other ways that My NCBI can bring more power
to a lot to the NCCBI database experience,
watch the previous NCBI Minute recordings
listed here on Tailoring your PubMed search
experience, and automating searches and saving
collections.
The online help for My NCBI is very comprehensive
and is truly helpful if you get stuck or are
not sure of all of your options on all of
these screens. I added the link to the online
help.
If anybody has any questions that were not
answered?
Thanks Marie. Actually there were a lot of
questions not answered because I don't know
a lot about this particular topic, to be honest.
I will go through them and hopefully you can
help answer.
There is a mixed bag of things. People are
asking general questions about My NCBI and
My Bibliography. By the way, if we do not
know the answers I will find them out and
get them in that document.
The first one is, if you change institutions
and your My NCBI account is through that institution
how do you retain your data?
So I have never tried to do that. You absolutely
can. That happens all the time. Working both
in education and on the help desk I would
be aware if that is something you cannot do.
I'll put that answer in the document that
Peter will include in the Materials, in terms
of the exact steps for transferring everything
if you are affiliated with one institution.
You may have addressed this I was looking
at the question pod. Forgive me.
Can individual authors edit their past records
to include ORCID IDs?
It by record you are saying PubMed citations,
no authors cannot, publishers can.
Honestly if you reach out to a publisher,
and either they are no longer -- it has to
be the publisher, the active data provider
for that journal, that is another thing that
switches a lot is data for a journal once
submitted by High Wire, might be submitted
by Elsevier or by a third-party vendor. We
always ask authors to reach out to the publisher,
they have a very user friendly system they
can use to edit any of the citation data that
they provide or they are allowed to provide,
they cannot edit Mesh terms obviously, but
if the publisher were to write back and say
I cannot do that, we can certainly do that
for you.
There are a couple of general My NCBI questions.
How do we get our institution added to the
third-party list for login options?
I think the best course for that would be
to email info@ncbi.nlm.nih.gov. They are the
best help desk to route that request to the
My NCBI developers and work on adding that
to the list.
Can you share part of the bibliography instead
of everything?
Honestly the way I would do that, a bibliography
is a collection called My Bibliography. You
could create another collection called, Joe
Smith bibliography, and have that be a subset
and share that. That is the way I would do
it, make one or the other the subset. I would
tend to keep My Bibliography as the superset,
because you can import citations from your
bibliography right into your SciEncv. So you
could create other collections for the subsets
of your complete bibliography, call it anything
you want. Those collections act the same way
as a bibliography and you would be able to
access the URL and share it.
You probably did address this. Where does
one go to create ORCID ID?
I might run through my slide so that I am
not wrong. I think it is ORCID.org. Yes. Takes
about 30 seconds. It might have been faster
for me since I don't have any publications
to link, but creating the ORCID ID itself
takes about 30 seconds, and it is free.
Is there an option to transfer bibliography
to the Endnote or other software?
I should know this, but I can get the answer
to that question. If you have any list of
citations in PubMed, you can export them to
an mbib file even if it's a question of looking
at those results, looking at the collection
in PubMed and using the Send to from there,
but if there is an easier way I will add it
in Peter's document.
We have a couple of people asking about the
slides, the compressed link that I sent out
does work. One possibility for some of you,
it is on FTP site, it's possible that is not
accessible to your computer for some reason.
I will send the uncompressed ftp URL, you
can change the first part of the address to
HTTPS if that helps.
One question someone asked, if you have a
public bibliography, is it searchable by Google?
(the answer seems to be, No)
Okay. The other question. Is the PubMed author
clustering algorithm publicly available?
I'm not sure if that one is. We typically
put them into the online help. If you go to
help in PubMed, then search for Sort by author,
or author. Typically we do include those algorithms,
whether it's that one or similar articles
or relevance, if it is not I will check and
see if I can track that down.
Okay we have time for one more question. This
one may be one you have mentioned in passing
during the webinar, I'm not sure. Can you
demo sending a suggestion to a co-author to
add a cite to a bibliography?
Sure. This way you'll see how I sign into
My NCBI.
Okay. Now I am signed in as me and I will
go to My NCBI, and I will go to my bibliography
and go to Manage My Bibliography. Then there
is a suggestion. Oops, I need to select something
first. I think I have a co-author here, and
literally you put their name, their email.
If I decide to send it to myself, then they
will get an email. That is as simple as it
is.
Okay I think that is all we have time for,
there are some unanswered questions in the
questions pod, I will be sure to get them
into a document.
Okay, thanks Marie, and thank you everybody
for coming, I will go ahead and end the webinar
now.